FIREARMS?
NO, I DIDN'T KNOW.
IF I HAD KNOWN, I WOULD HAVE
REPORTED HIM.
>> CNN'S DREW GRIFFIN TAKES A
LOOK AT THE GUNMAN'S TEXTS
BEFORE THE MASSACRE.
THIS REPORT DOES INCLUDE SEVERAL
IMAGES OF THE SHOOTER.
>> THIS IS THE TEXT CONVERSATION
JUST MOMENTS BEFORE THE
18-YEAR-OLD SUSPECT WOULD
ATTEMPT TO KILL HIS GRANDMOTHER,
THEN IN HIS WORDS, SHOOT UP AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GOING TO DO
RIGHT NOW, HE WRITES, TELL ME IS
THE RESPONSE.
I CAN'T, SINCE ME GRANDPA HASN'T
LEFT.
I'M WAITING FOR THIS DUDE TO
LEAVE.
SHORTLY AFTER 11:00 A.M., TEXAS
TIME, THE SUSPECT THEN COMPLAINS
ABOUT HIS GRANDMOTHER AND HIS
PHONE BILL.
I'M WAITING FOR THIS BITCH.
I'M GOING TO DO SOMETHING TO HER
RIGHT NOW.
SHE'S ON WITH AT&T ABOUT MY
PHONE.
IT'S ANNOYING.
FIVE MINUTES PASS, THEN, I JUST
SHOT MY GRANDMA IN THE HEAD.
I'M GONNA GO SHOOT UP AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL RIGHT NOW.
THAT LAST MESSAGE SENT AT 6:21
P.M. GERMAN TIME, WHICH WOULD
HAVE BEEN 11:21 A.M. IN UVALDE,
TEXAS.
11 MINUTES LATER, POLICE
RECEIVED THEIR FIRST CALL OF A
SHOOTING AT ROBB ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL.
THE PERSON ON THE RECEIVING END
OF THOSE TEXTS, A 15-YEAR-OLD
GIRL IN GERMANY.
SHE HAD NEVER MET THE SUSPECT IN
PERSON.
THEY CONNECTED THROUGH A
LIVESTREAMING APP CALLED UBO.
THEN FACETIME, TEXTED.
HE SENT HER VIDEOS OF HIMSELF.
SHE'S NOT THE ONLY PERSON HE WAS
COMMUNICATING WITH.
THE SHOOTER'S INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT
SHOWS A PHOTO OF TWO AR STYLE
WEAPONS AND TAGGED ANOTHER YOUNG
WOMAN WHO HE MESSAGED THE
MORNING OF THE SHOOTING SAYING
I'M ABOUT TO BUT DIDN'T FINISH
HISENTENCE, AND THEN, I GOT A
LITTLE SECRET.
JAKE, THE TEENAGE GIRL WHO SPOKE
TO CNN FROM GERMANY DID SO WITH
HER MOTHER'S CONSENT AND SHE
SAYS THAT REACHING OUT TO HIM
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA WAS HER
ONLY CONNECTION.
JAKE.
>> ALL RIGHT, DREW, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>> THE SURVIVORS AND IMMEDIATE
COMMUNITY AROUND UVALDE SUFFER
THE MOST ACUTE PAIN, OF COURSE,
BUT TRYING TO COMPREHEND
TRAGEDIES SUCH AS THIS ONE, THE
SADNESS, THE FEAR, THE ANGER,
CAN IMPACT THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
ALL OF US.
HERE TO HELP US UNDERSTAND THIS
MOMENT, KAREN PRICE, CHIEF OF
PSYCHOLOGY AT TEXAS CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL.
YOU LEAD A TEAM WORKING WITH THE
VICTIMS AND COMMUNITIES
SPECIFICALLY IN UVALDE.
WHAT IS YOUR TEAM SAYING TO
THEM?
HOW CAN YOU HELP THEM?
>> SO DURING THIS INITIAL PHASE,
REALLY, IT'S MORE FOCUSED ON
HELPING THE COMMUNITY GET
THROUGH THE CRISIS, TO GET
THROUGH THE TRAGEDY.
BUT WITH AN EYE TOWARD BUILDING
BACK THE COMMUNITY AND BUILDING
BACK RESILIENCE.
SO THIS REALLY TAKES THE FORM OF
TALKING WITH FAMILIES, TALKING
WITH SCHOOL PERSONNEL, TALKING
WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS, TALKING
WITH PARENTS ABOUT WHAT THEY CAN
EXPECT TO SEE, HOW THEY CAN HELP
THEIR CHILDREN TO MANAGE THE
STRONG EMOTIONS THAT OF COURSE
THEY'RE GOING TO FEEL DURING
THIS TIME.
WHAT TO LOOK FOR IN TERMS OF
SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS THAT THINGS
MAY NOT BE GOING WELL AND THAT
THEY MAY NEED PROFESSIONAL HELP.
>> ARE THERE ENOUGH MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES IN PLACE TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY
RIGHT NOW?
AND WILL THERE BE IN SIX MONTHS
FROM NOW?
>> SO NATIONALLY, OF COURSE,
WE'RE HAVING A CHILD MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS.
WE KNOW THAT THE COMMUNITY OF
UVALDE IS GOING TO NEED THAT
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT.
SO THINKING ABOUT WHAT SERVICES
WE CAN OFFER NOW AND WHAT
SERVICES WE PLAN TO OFFER IN THE
FUTURE, INCLUDING SENDING
CLINICIANS WHO ARE TRAINED IN
TRAUMA TO THE COMMUNITY TO HELP
THEM DEAL WITH THIS CRISIS.
>> SO THERE ARE FAMILIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, MAYBE EVEN AROUND
THE WORLD, WHO WOKE UP THIS
MORNING AND WERE TERRIFIED.
PARENTS AND KIDS SCARED TO GO TO
SCHOOL.
LET'S START WITH THE PARENTS.
HOW SHOULD PARENTS MANAGE
FEELINGS THAT THEY MAY HAVE
ABOUT FEAR, ANXIETY, SADNESS, IN
A HEALTHY WAY?
WHAT'S THE BEST WAY FOR MOM,
DAD, OR A GUARDIAN?
>> SO THE FIRST THING IS FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE PARENTS, LIKE
MYSELF, TO GET THEIR OWN
SUPPORT.
SO WHETHER THAT IS TALKING WITH
FRIENDS, WITH FAMILY MEMBERS,
WITH PARTNERS, WITH OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY ABOUT
THEIR FEELINGS.
SHARING THEM, TALKING ABOUT
THEM.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
BUT IT'S ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT
TO BRING THOSE FEELINGS BETTER
UNDER MANAGEMENT, BETTER UNDER
CONTROL WHEN THEY'RE PREPARING
TO TALK WITH THEIR CHILDREN
ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN'S FEELINGS
AS WELL.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE KIDS
NOW.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT HOW YOUNG
MINDS PROCESS THIS?
WHAT DO KIDS NEED EMOTIONALLY TO
UNDERSTAND OR DEAL WITH THE NEWS
OF WHAT HAPPENED IN TEXAS?
>> THE FIRST THING THAT THEY
NEED ARE ADULTS AROUND THEM WHO
CARE ABOUT THEM, WHO CAN PROVIDE
THEM WITH A STABLE ENVIRONMENT
AND WITH STRUCTURE, AND WITH
ROOM TO COMMUNICATE AB